no es un evento de graduación de la
escuela secundaria es un concierto
pagado en un sótano de shibuya uno de
los distritos festivos de tokio son solo
las tías de la mañana pero los
seguidores están descontrolados
[Aplausos]
así todo público es masculino todos
querían ver a su ídolo un término que en
japon designa a las estrellas de la
música pop idolatradas por sus
seguidores la receta de su éxito
disfraces sexys pero con un encanto
infantil para los seguidores encarnan a
la mujer perfecta la chica de sus sueños
[Música]
hay más de 10.000 ídolos en japonés
como reina que ha estado haciendo este
trabajo desde hace un año
hoy estamos vestidas como chicas de
secundaria en el escenario presta
atención a cada cliente
pienso en sus deseos y los miro a los
ojos en el momento adecuado
señales permanentes y palabras de amor
es mucho más que un concierto su
coqueteo pero sin besos
[Música]
las ídolos y los seguidores tienen una
relación que pretende ser sentimental
aunque siempre platónica
la ídolo la que libera pasiones en una
sociedad japonesa generalmente rígida en
el punto álgido del concierto la
estrella como en trance incluso se baja
del escenario para agradecer a sus
seguidores sin importar la sagrada
distancia social en japón
[Aplausos]
debido al coronavirus hace mucho tiempo
que no teníamos esto y nos hemos estado
conteniendo un poco hoy
normalmente nos soltamos mucho más nos
excita cuando están tan cerca de
nosotros
en los últimos 10 años esta industria de
la fantasía ha estado en auge en japón y
trae un montón de dinero más de 60
millones de álbumes vendidos por akb48
[Aplausos]
la segunda banda más popular en la
historia de la música japonesa su
particularidad ha tenido 300 miembros
desde su existencia porque una vez que
son demasiado viejas las estrellas dan
paso a unas más jóvenes ídolos como
productos de consumo cuyo destino es
habitado por la popularidad
esta matemática maribel
reglas escritas poniendo la vida de los
artistas prohibido tener novios as
ídolos deben permanecer disponibles para
sus seguidores la mayoría de los cuales
son solteros este fenómeno está
recibiendo críticas porque los ídolos
son cada vez más jóvenes
en este grupo tienen entre 11 y 13 años
la mayoría de los seguidores tienen la
misma edad que sus padres
[Aplausos]
al final del concierto el momento más
esperado por los seguidores el encuentro
por 29 dólares tienen derecho a una foto
autografiada y a un minuto de discusión
cronometrada
y
son fotos para su colección personal que
pueden ser compartidas en internet miles
de seguidores gastan mucho dinero en
nuestras reuniones como este hombre que
gasta más de 586 dólares al mes en ellas
como explicarle lo que me atrae es que
son chicas muy femeninas
físicamente es salada en la que son más
hermosas no cree entre las chicas y las
mujeres creo que es la edad en la que
brillan más
con palabras al límite de la pedofilia
pero estos hombres dicen que no tienen
atracción sexual solo una admiración
idealizada por estas chicas según los
padres de estas jóvenes nadie pasa a los
límites los casos de agresión sexual o
física de seguidores a sus ídolos son un
poco frecuentes arribará son controladas
por agentes que se llevan una parte de
las utilidades
la gente piensa que es peligroso porque
las chicas están un poco desnudas pero
es porque están desnudas que hay un
acompañamiento una estructura con
agentes y siempre la supervisión de los
padres
para entender cómo está atracción por
las chicas se ha convertido en una
fantasía colectiva nos vamos a akihabara
el distrito del manga en el corazón de
tokio
aquí las heroínas de los dibujos
animados y los videojuegos están por
todas partes hipersexualizadas y al
mismo tiempo infantiles
en todas partes también las que atraen a
los clientes a los bares y tiendas
según este productor de conciertos de
ídolos muy pocos fans tendrían deseos
adultos por estas niñas ellos mismos
quisieran volver a ser niños y así
escapar de sus dificultades diarias hoy
en día el costo de vida es alto en japon
- gente se casan y tienen hijos los
seguidores de ídolos trabajan en
entornos difíciles están estresados a
diario cuando van a los conciertos de
repente empiezan a imitar a las ídolo
sur y bailan como si fueran niños
es como si ajustarán su edad mental a
las chicas que tienen delante como si
estuvieran al mismo nivel y así se
sintieran mejor es una especie de
terapia para ellos
esta cultura expresa un malestar social
en un país donde cada vez hay más gente
soltera se dice que hay 3 millones de
seguidores de ídolos en japón